découvre d'abord que vous mettez en
scène même en pleine opération pendant
regarder une liposuccion sur un jeune
passion
toute l'opération est filmée
alors on est en direct du bloc
opératoire ici à Dubaï là je suis en
train de faire une liposuccion haute
définition 360 je parle français parce
que c'est un patient français très jeune
c'est un homme de 20 ans qui qui a déjà
des bonnes bases mais qui voulaient
vraiment avoir un niveau supérieur en
termes de look athlétique musculaire
[Musique]
et vous faites des nombres réductions à
certains clients contre de la publicité
je vous dis voilà ce qu'il y a des rongé
après il va nous répondre et c'est pour
ça qu'il est là regarde
il a obtenu une ristourne de 80% en
signant un contrat commercial avec le
chirurgien ma manager lui a proposé
différentes options minimales maximales
intermédiaire et ça suit des règles bien
précises on a même un contrat un accord
soit oblige donc Robin à parler de son
op
éra million d'abonnés sur les réseaux
sociaux une pratique interdite en France
mais pas à Dubaï où elle est très
répandue et le partenariat commence
maintenant je suis avec Docteur Matt
alors c'est officiel je vous l'annonce
demain docteur Malte va m'opérer
donc voilà qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ce reportage M6 bon déjà remettre un peu
les choses dans leur contexte le
reportage qui était présenté n'était pas
du tout ce qui m'avait été présenté
quand on était censé faire quelque chose
de très sérieux le on commence par le
titre les dérives et les scandales de la
chirurgie esthétique quand j'ai vu le
titre que je connaissais pas déjà ça m'a
fait sauter de mon ciel parce que on
n'était pas du tout dans ce cas là je
peux comprendre du coup à la base à la
base on devait parler de Robin ce jeune
Français influenceur qui voilà qui qui
essaie de s'en sortir dans la vie qui
est pas un vrai influenceur il travaille
vous l'avez vous l'avez vu ici et puis
qu'il y avait donc des problèmes avec
avec son corps et notamment avec les
saints il avait une gyné
[Musique]
un gros impact psychologique il est
affecté par son corps je rappelle la
définition la santé bien-être physique
psychique sociale il est pas bien dans
sa peau il est atteint psychiquement et
on est dans une société on n'est pas sur
une île déserte donc on est dans un
monde où il y a de plus en plus le
l'image qui compte les réseaux sociaux
les nouvelles génération des 20 ans moi
j'ai une fille de 20 ans et ben oui
effectivement elle fait attention à son
look et à la boite jolie elle est pas
bien dans sa peau et c'est c'est
acceptable on écoute les patients à
partir de quel âge vous acceptez
d'opérer d'abord je rappelle quelque
chose moi je suis chirurgien plastique
et la chirurgie plastique pédiatrique ça
existe il y a des gens qui sont opérés
qui font opérer leurs gamins des
oreilles décollées à 8 ans donc on peut
aussi se poser des questions est-ce que
ça vaut le coup de se repérer est-ce que
c'est justifier est-ce que c'est louable
d'opérer des oreilles décoller à 8 ans
donc lui il avait une gynécomatie à 22
ans je suis désolé c'est pas quelque
chose d'inacceptable en tout cas je
voulais dire nous on fait des choses
tout à fait normal sérieuse et avant de
d'accepter de l'opérer j'ai bien discuté
avec lui et j'ai accepté c'est lui qui
est venu me voir c'est pas moi
je pense qu'il faut pas le juger les
gens qui font de la chirurgie esthétique
en revanche qui me gêne c'est la manière
dont vous en faites la promotion c'est à
dire qu'on a l'impression que c'est un
produit une prestation lambda et j'ai
peur que ça crée des complexes à des
gens qui n'en ont pas au départ et que
ces personnes parce que là le mec il a
une réduction de 80 % vous vous êtes un
chirurgien reconnu mais qui les gens qui
se disent il faut absolument que je
fasse de la chirurgie esthétique et donc
je vais faire appel à n'importe qui un
chirurgien bidon à cause duquel je vais
avoir de graves problèmes de santé donc
est-ce que vous avez pas peur que la
manière dont vous en faites la promotion
ça peut être dangereux pour pour les
jeunes alors d'abord vous dire que au
début moi je voulais pas que ça soit
médiatisé il voulait absolument que ça
le soit pour effectivement avoir eu soit
une gratuité soit une une remise
significat significative et je lui dis
NON je lui dis sincèrement je veux pas
moi je veux de la tranquillité d'esprit
j'ai fait pas mal d'influenceurs par le
passé mais c'est seulement c'est pas la
patience elle que je recherche moi je
préfère le bouche-à-oreille les gens
confidentiels et j'ai fait j'ai opéré
des célébrités
qui sont absolument anonyme personne ne
le sait et je préfère ça après il est
revenu à la charge 6 mois après avec
Zone Interdite bon zone interdit c'est
quand même une émission sérieuse même si
à Dubaï j'aurais pas la télé j'avais en
tête que Zone Interdite était très
sérieux depuis plus de 20 ans donc je me
suis dit pourquoi pas faire un peu
d'information pour ma patienter le
français donc j'ai accepté mais j'ai pas
dit non j'ai pas dit oui tout de suite
je peux vous garantir donc
d'avoir dit oui non sincèrement je dis
je dis je regrette pas mais c'est
important d'avoir ce droit de réponse
parce que le reportage qui a été
présenté ne dépeint pas du tout la
réalité des choses ça a été caricaturé
comme toujours ou comme souvent les
journalistes c'est tourner sous des
angles polémiques qui sont juste des
fois juste incorrectes il a été très peu
mentionné des choses très importantes
comme ce que je vous ai dit la
gynécomatie la fibrose n'aime pas la
psychologique faut pas négliger les
choses et on banalise pas non plus une
petite lipo à la liposuccion c'est pas
une un geste simple et il y a c'est pas
vous là mais regarde il y a plusieurs
facteurs qui explique le développement
de la chirurgie chez les jeunes parmi
eux les filtres sur les réseaux sociaux
regardez Inès une jeune femme de 27 ans
on trouverait une photo d'elle avec un
filtre à son chirurgien regardez
dès qu'elle se filme ou se prend en
photo elle utilise une application qui
retouche son visage cette beauté
virtuelle Inès fait tout pour
l'atteindre dans la vraie vie et pour
cela elle a recours à un autre
subterfuge est-ce que le résultat au
niveau du nez est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir ça ou pas
je rappelle 99% des gens sur cette
planète ne sont pas français faut pas
croire quand même que la France du monde
on a un peu tendance nous Français
c'est en matière d'écologie on va dire
de chirurgie tu crois que la France va
sauver le monde je commence déjà sauvé
ton couple non mais je rigole merci
beaucoup oui
moi je vais être très désagréable alors
elle elle
vous en parle c'est en fait c'est la
banalisation de l'acte médical j'ai vu
votre insta par exemple vous montrer par
exemple les rosements de fesses et tout
ça mais en fait à aucun moment vous
parlez des risques des séquelles de si
ça se passe bien vous voyez il y a un
truc un peu vous vendez en fait la
chirurgie esthétique comme en fait un
code promo pour une french pédicure ou
un code promo pour un jean et moi ça me
gêne ça parce que malgré tout c'est les
jeunes les jeunes qui regardent beaucoup
aussi aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux et
quand on est jeune oui on peut se faire
faire recoller les oreilles quand on a 6
ans la chirurgie réparatrice et la
chirurgie de l'embellissement parce
qu'on veut ressembler à un livre avec un
pardon un filtre ou à une héroïne de
télé-réalité moi ça ça me gêne un petit
peu et je trouve que du coup votre
discours il est un tout petit peu
malhonnête je me permettrai pas mais un
peu biaisé et moi j'ai peur que ça
malgré tout sa traumatise et la jeune
génération je vous remercie mais en fait
si vous avez vu un peu moins Instagram
je suis par ailleurs je fais beaucoup de
formations médicales d'ailleurs je passe
la semaine à Paris pour justement le
Congrès mondial de chirurgie plastique
et là pour une formation j'étais juste
avant et juste après à former des
médecins donc la sécurité les
complications c'est notre priorité vous
savez on en parle beaucoup si vous
regardez mes derniers mes derniers
postes c'est parfait de dire qu'il y a
des risques quand on se fait remonter
les fesses ou quand on alors justement
on va voir une opération de remontage de
fesses c'est cloué qui a voulu refaire
ses fesses la tendance c'est des fesses
bombées voilà elles se sentait complexée
en fait c'est les fesses les fesses bon
ben ça toujours été les fesses bombées
ou là vous avez la chance hier ici tout
savoir les Facebook B c'est bien voilà
pour augmenter le volume d'un fessier il
existe deux techniques les implants ou
l'injection de graisse plus souvent
appelée Bébél pour brasilienne but
l'opération consiste à lui prélever la
graisse du ventre et des cuisses pour
lui réinjecter dans chaque fesse
pourtant elle comporte un gros risque
celui de faire une embolie graisseuse en
clair que la graisse réin viennent
boucher les veines l’opération se fait
sous anesthésie générale une fois la
graisse du ventre et des cuisses
aspirées près de 400 seringues en tout
celle-ci est purifiée une centaine de
seringues et près de 4 heures son
nécessaire pour son nouveau fessier et
il vaut mieux que la forme lui plaise
car cette intervention coûte 7000 euros
le résultat puisqu'elle est plutôt fière
du résultat Chloé voilà je sais que je
sais pas si vous l'avez déjà fait vous
ici il y en a qui ont déjà fait mais
voilà pour toi Raymond c'est très réussi
je commence à avoir vraiment les
résultats enfin et je me dis que ça ne
sera que mieux même dans un à deux mois
alors
tes commandes
pour conserver sa nouvelle silhouette et
ses fesses rebondies Chloé doit
maintenant avoir une hygiène de vie
irréprochable
à bientôt on doit avoir une hygiène de
vie irréprochable après absolument
on doit changer de lifestyle si on fait
une chirurgie
non mais parce que pourquoi elle est
investir en temps énergie
financier s'il y a par ailleurs on mange
mal on fume donc faut que ça soit
logique globale et puis aussi ça
potentialise
c'est très mauvais faut se mettre au
sport Robin que vous avez ici il
mangeait mal il bougeait pas donc je lui
ai dit je t'opère uniquement si tu
m'écoutes après
je fume pas qu'est-ce que tu cherches
une bête oui ce qui me dérange docteur
vous dites tout à l'heure je suis très
bon d'ailleurs je vais faire je vais
donner des cours en formation donc j'ai
aucun doute sur vos qualités et bien
justement un médecin c'est pas c'est pas
magasin Levi's si vous êtes bon il y
aura un bouche à oreille les grands
chirurgiens à Paris ou en France il y a
zéro pub il y a du bouche à oreille
parce que on choisit pas un chirurgien
comme un jean on se renseigne bouche à
oreille on va sur des sites on regarde
ses diplômes et vous vous arrivez à
Dubaï vous dites j'ai pas de clientèle
donc je fais de la pub si vous êtes bon
docteur comme vous le dites il y aura le
bouche à oreille ça va donc c'est un
médecin ne fait pas de publicité
qu'est-ce qui répond à ça moi je dis
d'abord que les gens ont besoin
d'informations donc il y a toujours eu
un lien très étroit un peu ambigu entre
l'information et la publicité en France
il y en a le droit à l'information il y
a pas le droit à la publicité directe à
Dubaï c'est différent moi je suis à
Dubaï je suis la loi de Dubaï il faut
l'accepter encore une fois Dubaï c'est
pas la France et ça vous viendrait pas
l'idée d'aller voir un médecin que vous
connaissez ni la dent ni-dave il vous
avez quand même besoin de savoir qui il
est pour ça et c'est important voilà
donc on a besoin
bien sûr
mais on a quand même besoin de de mettre
de faire connaître aux gens ce que l'on
fait il y a le savoir-faire il y a le
faire savoir et vous avez besoin malgré
tout de montrer un peu ce que vous
voulez si vous êtes le meilleur du monde
sur l'île déserte personne vous connaît
oui mais ça sert à quoi vous allez
attaqué M6 pour ça alors c'est une bonne
question alors vous avez d'abord
l'impression que c'est un vous allez
[Rires]
je vais vous dire sincèrement j'étais
surpris pour ne pas dire déçu du
reportage parce qu'il y avait beaucoup
mieux à faire aussi bien sur Robin que
sur moi que sur Dubaï sincèrement c'est
caricatural polémiques et j'ai été
plutôt déçu du reportage faut pas croire
que parce que je suis passé à Zone
Interdite ça m'a fait sauter de joie
j'étais vraiment enthousiaste je croyais
qu'ils avaient ils avaient vraiment
tourné des plein de choses et il y a
rien ou très peu qui est passé il y a
une phrase dans le reportage que je
considère diffamatoires que je cite
texto vous l'aurez compris à Dubaï le
serment d'Hippocrate n'est qu'un
lointain souvenir j'ai l'extrait
dans 2 minutes
jour eu un peu une une contradiction
entre la médecine et comme si les
médecins ne pouvaient pas gagner
d'argent parce que c'est la santé ou
parce que ça touche au corps le métier
le médecin évolue on essaie de devenir
un peu des entrepreneurs mais maintenant
et voilà c'est comme tout faut faire
tourner la boutique à Dubaï vous l'aurez
compris le serment d'Hippocrate n'est
plus qu'un loin en souvenir
alors dans ta gueule de l'homo
merci c'est c'est ça la phrase on peut
discuter de tout on peut être d'accord
pas d'accord cette phrase elle est
diffamatoire d'accord donc là pour ça
vous vous posez la question ben je les
ai contacté M6 au fait les meunier Kevin
dantzler on verra bien ce qui raconte
pour l'instant il répond pas d'accord
bon bah vous nous tiendrez au courant
merci vous êtes là pour l'instant vous
êtes ici sur la formation médicale juste
pour vous répondre par rapport aux
complications premièrement j'en parle
beaucoup mais ça dépend à quelle
audience on parle beaucoup notamment à
mes collègues je suis là justement pour
la prévention des complications les
complications c'est vraiment notre
priorité vous savez nous on est sous
pression faut bien comprendre que la
chirurgie plastique c'est pas non plus
ce qu'on montre à la télé les
caricatures américaines on est sous
pression et faire un reportage comme ça
c'est prendre beaucoup de risques
sincèrement heureusement ça s'est très
bien passé avec Robin imaginez que ça se
passe pas bien imaginez qu'il est une
complication ça fait la publicité
négative donc sincèrement tranquillité
d'esprit moi j'ai travaillé les
influenceurs à Dubaï quand j'arrivais
parce qu'elle a beaucoup d'abord ils
sont tous venus me voir j'ai demandé à
aucun de venir me voir ils sont tous
venus me voir les uns après les autres 1
2 4 8 et je les ai tous vu opérer pas
opéré peu importe et c'est comme ça que
ça se passe on va pas aller chercher
donc faut bien comprendre que les
complications ça arrive on peut avoir
une infection une anémie un nématome une
régularité mais après il faut savoir les
gérer et la différence entre un médecin
responsable et un médecin qui est
responsable c'est que il va gérer sa
complication comme un grand avec les
avec les capacités et le savoir-faire
donc moi j'ai jamais complication ça
m'arrive plus on opère plus on a de
complications il faut en être bien
conscient on ne néglige rien on fait un
travail très sérieux avant d'être
chirurgien esthétique on est un
chirurgien réparateur un chirurgien
général et un médecin tout court et le
serment d'Hippocrate c'est sacré ils ont
touché au serment d'Hippocrate je viens
d'une famille ouais que des médecins
perdent tout le monde des médecins
sincèrement c'est inacceptable de
remettre en cause pour une juste à se
comprendre dans le cas d'une émission de
zone interdite
très peu de photos vidéos sincèrement
c'était diffamatoire et rien que pour ça
ça mérite d'en parler